evènement c'est la ville étape qu'il a
choisi dans les yvelines pour s'arrêter
et faire signer son appel du ruban rouge
j'ai la misha l'on parcourt la france à
vélo à pied et en courant pour
sensibiliser les citoyens pour la lutte
contre le sida
une mobilisation qui lui rappelle que
les français ne se sentent pas toutes
concernées
arrivée à la mairie des vêtements voilà
en gros on va diffuser d'informations va
apporter de la pédagogie pour expliquer
que le sida ça concerne tout le monde
qui on peut y mettre fin
ghislaine ce n'est la mer des vêtements
se sent très impliquée par cette
démarche et se désole que sa ville soit
la seule à avoir accepté de recevoir la
boucle du ruban rouge
il ya le sida mais également le
paludisme c'est à ces trans partisan
donc non je suis assez je suis assez
étonné du fait qu'il n'ait pas voulu
accueillir 7 7 cette démarche et je
pense que tout le monde doit être
mobilisés contrôlant contre cette
maladie
pour l'association aides il était
primordial que la boucle passe en île de
france car c'est la région la plus
touchée par l'épidémie
il ya des personnes qui font familles
des deux personnes qui n'ont pas accès
aux soins au dépistage et d'avoir voilà
la maire d'une commune qui qui décide de
s'engager de signer notre appel pour
nous c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'essentiel la boucle du ruban rouge
sera donc bouclé le 10 octobre à lyon
après 1600 km pour intervenir sur le
fonds mondial de la lutte contre le sida